fertility clinic this was so crazy oh
god what happened here this isn't so
there's a couple from New York who
couldn't get pregnant and they ended up
going to this fertility clinic one of
the best ones here in California and all
over the country they ended up finding
out that when she gave birth she gave
birth to two beautiful boys that were
not Asian and the couple was Asian both
Asian and white kids uh they don't know
they don't specify what the kids were
but they were not Asian both parents are
Asian they pay to have their embryos
placed into the woman but they
accidentally put two embryos from two
different people into her do you know
I've told you I've even technically
related with the IVF co2 IBF and I made
two deposits on my bust busting pup
deposit yeah I busted in it and when I
left I thought I don't know if they keep
that and use it with other people
Oh we'd have no idea the question yeah
of course they unhealthiest slaughter
max so what happened to them well right
now they're suing cuz one she carried
the children to term two she had to give
the children back to the biological
biological parents also didn't know that
this was gonna happen so now they both
have kids to have sons and those sons
are asked if you could if you were
looking for a job we'll take this now
there are your child yeah that's crazy
so now they're suing the clinic for
emotional damages they're gonna give
them everything yeah and now they're
trying to figure out what happened with
their embryos because they actually
wanted to have girls and originally when
they I guess extracted the embryos that
they were gonna use they specifically
chose just girls but the wife heard
something a little odd when they put the
embryos inside her because they said
these are both they referred to the
embryos as boys and she just kind of
shrugged it off she didn't think too
much of it the day of she ended up
having two boys that were not Asian and
easy that'd be so hard but how that's
nine months nine whole months
dude the IVF - oh you gotta look into it
with my girl
because we're gonna have twins before we
made it happen naturally dick games on
point yeah yeah two boys who wants kids
him yeah natural state who wants a boy
I'll bust in your face so hey it's
really extensive be the success rate
ain't right on those IPs all right
that's very expensive every time you
have to do it yeah man my daddy got my
doctor such a tool - oh really the
jeebies yeah
he did my buddy Joey dr. kardashians him
oh my body just stem cells in his
shoulder shoulders and he'd been in pain
for like fifteen years he goes dude it's
two years now it's been gone completely
yeah it really does work I'll hold on
give me a second
ya know 2016 with stems really yeah oh
yeah no no no Brian just found it okay
is that good no brought yeah your friend
Joe Rogan's been doing it for seven
years yeah but okay thank you
but every fighter and every athlete I
know does it thank you click but I
didn't know now what they're doing
though is there's a new procedure that's
gonna get like approved they're taking
the amniotic fluid from a woman's like
second trimester or something those stem
cells become yours if you get they'll
shoot you into your bloodstream and they
can mutate into becoming yours and they
become anything that you want them to be
so they they will be whatever you need
them to be essentially it's kind of
crazy so that there's this is the news
oh yeah let's go hair loss hair loss
hair loss hair loss and she didn't get
on that old daddy is a little sore in
the I'm achy I'm pushing a little hard
with the boxing slash lifting shoulders
are given out are they giving out little
danger there a sauce there a key my my
shoulders are a Kenny CBD oil dude yeah
they're hurt inflammation CBD oil yeah I
know a guy who owns the company
maybe I should warm up better to don't
do that in our or not or you know if do
you know I was just part of being 52
yeah
CBD oil would definitely help with that
inflammation rowdy all day all right
I'll take it
only Choji right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been
doing
[Laughter]